vous avez eu des gens mis en cache sexe
quand ça va recevoir des gros cadeau à
matignon et à huy et il devient de plus
en plus beaux gosses suis l'un des bus
qui l'a reçue petite culotte
ça c'est pas une bonne au regard des
actions culotté c'est un collectif d'une
centaine de détaillants en france avec
qui on a eu la bonne idée d'envoyer à
matignon à jean castex une petite
culotte une culotte pour lui dire à ce
monsieur castex que non nous ne sommes
pas non essentiels et que on a tout à
fait le droit d'être ouverte au même
titre que les autres commerce iep
disquaires jardinerie ça nous saoule
on en a gros je suis tellement d'accord
avec m
bravo à cette jeune fille je suis
d'accord à kehl on le dit depuis des
semaines et des semaines ici un gilbert
belle idée géniale en plus c'est vrai
que oui elles sont essentielles et le
fait de le faire comme ça avec humour
c'est repris par tous et j'espère
qu'elles vont se faire entendre
franchement c'est formidable bravo elle
très bonne démarche c'est à la fois
c'est provoquer ça dénonce une réalité
il ya plein d' absurdité aujourd'hui
dans les restrictions sanitaires
pourquoi les rayons lingerie sont
ouverts dans le supermarché et les
magasins de lingerie sont fermés
pourquoi les petites boutiques ont pris
sans que son pourquoi les petites
boutiques on reçoit que trois ou cinq
clients sont fermées donc je trouve ça
mais heureusement qu'on a fermé les
magasins c'est pour être comme ça je
pense qu'ils ont très bien fait huit ans
aucun danger oui elles disent que la
première chose qu'on fait le matin c'est
d'enfiler une culotte
ouais donc là c'est effectivement
essentiel et c'est pour ça qu'il ya ça
directeur castaldi donc dû jouer
aujourd'hui ça va les réveiller un jour
qu'astana oui non
j'aime sa femme avait donné les clés de
chez lui arrive à 4 heures du matin avec
une fanfare castaldi avec une fanfare
s'est retrouvé à poil pour moi c'est
magnifique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu n'auras je déteste le pyjama le slip
que j'aime pas du tout non j'aime bien
dans mes revenus vous n'êtes pas peur
qui est des trucs qui rentrent en vous
comme moi je suis pas dans une jungle où
elle est bonne culture est pas une
attaque dans les white dans le 17e
arrondissement salicorne expressément
vous à quoi à poil tout doux dont je
suis ne donne jusqu'au bout de la nuit
alors oui d'orense en fait l'histoire a
commencé des commerces mon essentiel
c'est une grosse faute de com en fait
essentiel et pas essentiels dont le
gouvernement ne s'est jamais départi
c'est les libraires sont loin de me la
pagaille au départ parce que comme on
avait fermé délibéré tout le monde s'est
offusqué la fermeture des librairies
alors qu'en fait la vérité c'est que
quand ça réouvert très peu de gens en
librairie et du coup ils vont fermer
mais super les rayons ordonné alors ils
ont fermé les rayons des supermarchés
pour ne pas faire de différence et herat
et on est arrivé dans le nom l'essentiel
est essentielle mais en fait c'est un
vrai problème de qom
parce qu'en fait il aurait dû dire
première nécessité c'est à dire manger
et c'est sûr que c'est essentiel il faut
signaler pour les femmes la situation
est plus compliquée quand même parce que
vous les hommes vous êtes un peu moins
apprêtée on va dire à tous regardé comme
un tueur gardez vous des femmes sauf
qu'aucun homme qui écrit à castex pour
lui dire qu'il a un problème de pilote
non mais veut dire quelque chose à moi
j'en ai moi j'en ai oui selon l'ifop
change de vêtements comme 73
en attendant la vérité qui ont déjà
remis deux fois l'om slip moi oui
conscient campi à la mer ou à la
montagne au camping 2 mais en même temps
je suis prêt d'arrêter mon temps mais
tais toi même si tu as we are il perdait
la wii quand vous dormez pas chez vous
par exemple si vous avez une absence ou
une souris ou rouge avec les bonnes
cibles se sent pas du tout lui même au
camping et lui dort toujours chez lui à
damas où sont des styles tous les jours
oui normalement oui ça m'est arrivé
voilà dormoy jamais tête de la veille
wheels a même jour le jour jamais mais
vaut mieux je crois que je vais rien à
la fraîche comme quand j'arrive à le
décoller mondial de poule
non mais c'est vrai ils devront la
mairie jean parfois se peut des fois je
mets pas tout bêtement fumée jing sur
romelu jean de poids de suie away
j'aurais pas de vos jeans